بنحب نرحب بضيفنا في الاستوديو شيف محمد
اورفلي اهلا بك اهلا وسهلا معنا
بعشرين سنه فكره الطعام تغيرت كثير الشيف
يعني تحول من شف لنجم المطاعم بدل ما تكون
مكان للاكل صارت هلا مكان للموضه للتجمع
ولظهور بنفس الوقت حتى
الاكل اللي الفاست فود اللي احنا بناكله
تحول لموضه كمان من وجهه نظرك كيف تغير
نظره العالم للطعام بعشرين سنه وحتى طعام
كاندا ستريكه صناعه هلا بني ادمين تغيرنا
من ثلاث سنين او اربع سنين
نحن تغيرنا بمنظومه الاكل تبعنا
اكيد غيرت انا بتذكر حالي ودخلت على
المدرسه الفندقيه واول مره اكلت بهدله من
امي يعني طويله عريضه وشرشحت العيله
بالنسبه لالهن انه كيف يطلع دكتور محامي
ومهندس طلع طباخ
فكانت تشالنج بالنسبه لي كانت جدا يعني
صعبه بالبدايه لحتى هذا التحدي انه ابرهن
للناس اخذت معي اكثر من 20 سنه فمن قبل
كنا نخجل انه نقول انه هذا الشيف او طباخ
او حتى الشيف يروح على الشغل ما يلبس
جاكيت تبعته هلا بتشوف الشيف لا براود
اباوت
فخور اظن السوشيال ميديا غير التلفزيون
غير أنا تغيرت حياتي قبل الوقت كنت شيف
بشتغل بمطعم ورجعت اشتغلت بالتلفزيون اكثر
من 12 سنه منظور الناس اتغيرت للشيف وصار
الشيف اكثر ان ارتيست صارت اكثر من طباخ
وصار صار بالعكس العيال صاروا يعني يشجعوا
اولادهم على المدرسه فندقيه يطلع الولد
الطباخت التغير اللي صار بعشرين سنه مثلا
اتفضلي من هذا التغير انه في مقابله لك
بتحكي فيها انه في البدايات ربما صعوبه
الوصول الى المعلومه او الوصول الى الوصفه
الوصول الى الطريقه خاصه بالتمانينات
كان تحدي كبير بالنسبه لك هلا هذا التحدي
بطل موجود صار في الوصفات موجوده
على
الانترنت على تيك توك كل محل بعلمك كيف
ممكن تطبخ حتى على طريقه
هلا كيف ممكن الواحد يتميز مع كل
المعلومات المتاحه يعني زمان الشخص كان هو
اللي بيمتلك الوصفه هلا اللي بيمتلك شو
هاي عذبتني كتير انا كنت اشتغل مع واحد
ميرفت سكر مش
خلاني امشي على البيت مشاني من الشغل لانه
كنت انا كتير فضولي بدي اعرف شو عم يعمل
يعني حتى بدي اعرف
الشغل تبعه يعني كان عنده كم شغله يحطهم
بالاكل يعني خلينا نروح نعمل شيء ثاني
مشان ما نشوفوا شو عم بيحطوا الاكل فكانت
المنظور للاكل انه في اسرار والشيف عنده
خلطاته السريه او بهاراته السريه انا
برايي ما في اسرار بالاكل الاسرار الا هو
النفس النفس هي الطاقه والانرجي انت
بتعطيها للاكل فبتحطي طاقه بالاكل بطلع
طيب راجعه من البيت راجعه من الشغل تعبانه
بدك تعملي اكل للاولاد ما رح يطلع متل ما
انت مروقه نهار الويكان طالعه على بالك
تطبخي لهم طبخه معينه راح تطلع الاكل عن
جد غير الاكل فيه نفس وفيه طاقه شو ما
كانت المكونات اذا اعطي نفس الطبخه لعشر
اشخاص كل واحد بطبخها شكل نرجع لمنظور
المعلومات تعذبت كتير يعني مثلا ما كنت
انا كنت على عمري انزل ما في انترنت لا في
سوشيال ميديا الحل الوحيد انه طلع كتاب
حتى اذا تعذب بلاقي كتاب باللغه
الانجليزيه يعني كنت تلاقيهم كلهم بالعربي
فكان الدوري على المعلومه كانت عن جد صعبه
فعلمتني كتير انه اعطتني جلد وصبر لحتى
اتعلم واوصل اللي بدي اياه هلا صار بالعكس
هلا من كتر المعلومات صرت تضيعي
انا اي خط لازم اخذ من مين بدي اخذ
المعلومه صح ولا ولا غلط فراي دائما
اذا بدنا ناخذ معلومه طبخ مزبوطه بنرجع
لمصدر موثوق يكون شاف معروف
عندهم مطعم عنده او عنده برامج بالطبخ او
يعني يكون معتمد او موثوق لانه في كثير
صراحه وصفات بتشوفيها بتقولي يا لطيف بس
بالاخر المقله والدله الاكل الطيب ما بده
كتير
طيب يعني اول اول اول وصفه كتبت في كتاب
كانت في العصر العباسي اللي جمعت ما بين
المطبخ الحلبي
والمطبخ البغدادي او العراقي
اليوم انتم متهمين ايضا بانه رؤيتكم
الجديده للاطباق عم تشوهوا الاطباق لا
بالعكس ليه هلا بقول لك يعني هذه الدسامه
والنكهه القديمه يقولون والله اليوم الشيف
قدموها
اكثر
لايت خلينا نقول بعيدا عادل بده دسم بدك
دسم زياده
انا ضد اللي بقول لك الدسم
المكونات
ممتازه لشو بدك تختلط لون البهارات اللي
تطلع الاكل طيب الاكل الطيب مكوناته طيبه
بطلع جدا رائع اذا نرجع للزمن نحنا من 300
سنه ما بناكل نفس الاكل اللي اكلناه من
قبل لانه دخل علينا كتير مكونات غير
مكونات دخلت علينا من قبل ايام الطماطم
البندوره البطاطا الفلفل هدول كلهم ما
بنعرفهم امريكا لا لا نزرعوا بحلب
اول مره استعملوا الطماطم يعني على حسب
على تقريبا باواخر 1880 تقريبا ففي تذكير
تداخلات بالاكل تبعنا اذا نرجع للتاريخ
الاكل ما عليه ولا كلمه وانا
ثقافي حضاري والمشرب كتير قوي بس يحتاج
اعاده نظر بالموضوع يعني احنا تغيرنا انت
بتمشي مثل قبل قبل كانوا ما كان عندهم
باصات ولا عندهم شيء
لازم على وضعنا الحالي كشفت كمسؤول انا
يكون عندي نظره كيف اعمل منتنز للاكل
تبعنا من دون ما اخرب الروح تبعت الاكل
بدون ما اخرب الاصل تبع الاكل احنا للاسف
الوقت عم يدركنا بس انا بدي اقول شغله
وحده انه طبعا انت حائز مطعمك حائز
من اسبوعين تقريبا اخذنا افضل مطعم بشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا شفتي بسنت ذا وورد
الجائزه جدا رائعه
تعطينا معنويات ودفع العربي حلبي ولا
فيوجن
الكميوليتي تبعت دبي احنا كل الناس اللي
عايشه في الامارات
وهي خليط الفكره من الاكل تبعي انه كنت
اخدت زاويه او خط معين ما حدا يخدم قبل
اسمه مطبخ الاورفلي ما خصوا بشي بس جذوري
حلبيه والنفخر
وعايش انا بالامارات 17 سنه فتاسرت كثير
مطابخ مختلفه يعني اطبخي بابا حلبي حلبي
مركزه ولكن بتيجي لعندي على المحل في كم
اكله بفرجيكي منهن الروس تبعتنا والتاني
اللي هو خلينا نقول رؤيه كويزين هو دبي
كويزين او الامارات مطبخ الامارات الحديث
مثل ما صار بكذا بلد في العالم بلد متطور
وفيه كتير
على فكره الشاف اليوم فطران شو تجبر هذا
الاكل الصحي ههه
والله انا
من الصبح انا فطوري كمان
للشيف محمد اورفلي كان معنا في الاستوديو
شكرا